how's it going everybody it's Warren and
with just under one month until Avengers
end game comes out we have a brand new
plot league for the movie now I've been
avoiding doing plot leaks lately because
there are just so many of them out there
it's hard to tell if any of them or any
parts of them are legitimate or not but
this one is so different and honestly
something that I'd love to see play out
in the movie that I had to talk about it
obviously since it's a plot leaked I'm
going to issue my normal warning there
is no way to tell if this is legitimate
or not but if any of it ends up being
real there are going to be some huge
spoilers in this plot leaked but take it
with a grain of salt also if you're new
to my channel be sure to subscribe I do
monthly giveaways right now giving away
five imax tickets if you'd like to enter
for your chance to win all you have to
do is be subscribed to my channel like
this video and comment down below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain okay so this plot
leaked is of the entire movie and is
divided into three acts I'll go ahead
and read it
all the way through in its entirety and
then I'll talk about it after Act one
Tony and nebula make it back to earth
Captain Marvel is there and the entire
team heads to Thanos Thanos is weakened
and the team especially because of
Captain Marvel kill him the gauntlet is
broken and the stones can't undo the
snap
they couldn't protect the universe so
they avenged it Thanos meets death who
was the girl everyone thinks was casted
as ant man's daughter he is pleased with
himself that's the end of act 1 act 2 a
few years later ant-man returns out of
the quantum realm and he explains the
quantum realm and time vortexes to the
Avengers
Tony builds the quantum realm suits and
that team splits off to recharge the
stones at various points in time the
rest of the act is an interaction
between the past Avengers and the
present Avengers working in teams to
power up the stones but Thanos has been
watching the entire time and he is now
concerned that they could undo his plan
so he begs death to let him preserve his
work and that's the end of act 2 act 3
Thanos and the outriders attacked the
Avengers headquarters to prevent the new
gauntlet from being used Captain America
Tony and the Hulk quantum away to the
battle that will conduct using the new
gauntlet only to miss and end up ons and
are after Thanos his battle they're the
new gauntlet isn't strong enough to
defeat Thanos and there's
big fight between Captain America Tony
and the Hulk versus Thanos the fight
continues until it's eventually just
captain versus Thanos and Captain
America is able to use the Infinity
Gauntlet one last time saying Avengers
Assemble bringing everyone every single
hero to face Thanos this is the huge
fight scene with all of the heroes in
real time Thanos at Wakanda seized the
stones weakening from his gauntlet
because in this timeline he's defeated
Captain America sacrifices himself and
Thanos is killed at Wakanda and now the
snap never happened so the events of the
movie basically never happened
Doctor Strange does some hand-wave and
he says that the loop is now closed for
the 14th millionth time and that the
loop is now closed and that's it for
this plot leaked like I said it's
definitely different than all of the
other ones that we've heard so far
starting from the very beginning when
the Avengers actually kill Thanos a lot
of people think that the Avengers are
going to go fight Thanos initially and
lose again but let's remember what the
Russo brothers said in the Infinity war
commentary they said that the Infinity
Gauntlet and Thanos are permanently
damaged so it would make sense that
they'd kill him relatively easily and it
would also make sense that when they get
the stones they no longer work because
again the gauntlet was permanently
damaged after the snap the stones were
probably damaged as well but this plot
leak makes sense because the Avengers
aren't going back in time to take the
stones from the past they're taking the
stones from the future to the Past to
try and recharge them this makes sense
because you can't really alter timelines
this way taking the stones from the past
could severely alter the future making
it to where the events of age of Ultron
never happened to where Wanda and
Quicksilver got their powers and where
vision was born so the Avengers going
back in time to simply recharge the
stones from the present seems like it
could work and it wouldn't put their
current timeline at jeopardy and then
another part is death death was the
reason in the Infinity Gauntlet saga in
the comics that Thanos performed the
snap he was trying to win her love and
death was mentioned in the post-credits
scene for the very first Avengers movie
but since then we've heard nothing about
her but why would they mention her if
they're not trying to set her up she
plays such a huge role in the comics and
in this plot leaked I like how they put
her in the movie she's not Thanos his
main motivation for doing the snap
however she is clearly part of his life
somehow and
also a way for him to return after the
Avengers kill him as for the Avengers
working with the past Avengers this
seems to line up with the leaked set
photos that we've gotten in the past
where we see in what looks like the
Battle of New York and older Tony Stark
with a younger Captain America captain
Tony and the Hulk going on a mission
together also line up with a leaked set
photo as well because those three are
the ones in the photo and as far as
Thanos and the outriders attacking the
avengers headquarters goes we've already
seen this in a Lego leak before so this
lines right up with that and what's
interesting about this plot leak is that
it says the final battle will take place
on Xandar and everybody thinks that
we're going to see Xander and Avengers
in-game because it was not seen in
Avengers infinity war although it was
mentioned and of course the final battle
with all of the heroes and one scene a
huge scene with over 25 different heroes
is something that we've heard from the
actors themselves so there's a lot in
this plot leak that lines up with what
we currently know and there's also a lot
of twists that I think the Russo
brothers would throw at us including
Lady Death and the gauntlet and the
stones not working after the Avengers
killed Thanos initially there's
definitely a lot that could happen in
Avengers in game in this plot leak but
like I said take this with a grain of
salt there's no way to know if this is
legitimate or not but definitely be sure
to let me know what you think about this
is this something that you would like to
see played out in Avengers endgame and
if so what part did you like the most
let me know in the comments down below
and don't forget to subscribe comment
down below and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
on everything relating to marvel and
Avengers endgame as always thank you all
so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
[Music]